you're having so much success uh and
sort of popular success with films that
on the face of it you you don't think
would kind of resonate in the way that
they have like this or or call me by
your name i mean how surprised were you
when that film found this huge no
absolutely and i man that's why i'm so
honored to be up here with you laura as
well like uh i
i love movies i love acting i love going
to movies i was kind of getting scared
when i was younger that maybe was
becoming like opera or something like an
outdated art form or something uh
and
you see like circus movies you see
laura's movies you see steven's like the
you know these are these are great uh
hopefully these are great things and a
good way forward and the yourself and
army hammer when you weren't going by
your name so you yeah there you are yay
and you you get this wonderful
opportunity you go off to italy to make
it right but it sounds like the director
really threw you in at the the deep end
yes this is true so day one day one he
oh yeah i didn't win anything no we had
a rehearsal with army that um you know
we basically had to break the ice and
our army tells the story way better than
i do but uh we had to do a rehearsal
outside and luca made it seem very spur
of the moment like we wouldn't rehearse
any scene but then once we get outside
he like had a very specific page number
to turn to it happened to be the first
make out in the movie or the first kiss
so army and i were kind of like each
other like all right here we go and i'm
like
and uh so lucas said you know dive into
it and we started making out
and there was no stop there was no like
cut
so
we we like
wait like a minute or two minutes and
then like stop making out and luke was
gone
[Applause]
it's like looking in the mirror
yes it was like it was meant to be
but we're now discovering you know
everybody uh you've met regina well yes
yes my wife
so many people say we have six degrees
well
and of course you look alike is here as
well yeah yeah yeah this is this is this
is essentially what you would look like
if you were chopped off at the knees and
never went to the gym
[Laughter]
could
[Music]
you stunt doubles here really
ever now
jason emily you have seen each other
since game of thrones we have
yes
every time i come to england
oh and in fact i've just remembered so
because this goes out uh we're taping
this on thursday so this goes out
tomorrow night yes so will you tomorrow
night so when we went to be here we'll
be at my party we'll be at her party
are you going to amelia's party she
hasn't asked you do you want to i'd love
to cook there we are
yeah
as long as jesus
can swap clothes and i turn up first
[Applause]
oh
as wet as this coat is but
it is it is awful that's a big deal
[Laughter]
but i'm all for it
is it this
being bendy and doing the trapezy thing
was there a moment when i think you you
overexerted yourself it was it in front
of hugh okay see here's what happened
let me just clear the air literally so
here's the story literally all right
yeah so we're doing i'm not gonna name
the person because it's embarrassing
okay
the point is we're doing a stunt in
front of hugh jackman now i have very
few scenes with hugh jackman and um i
was very i was very nervous it was not
you
and um i was on my you know my a game
because this is hugh jackman i do not
want to mess up so we're doing this this
this this thing where i'm basically up
in the air and i spin down and i get
caught and i heard a fart
now wait we all are the fun
now
as a professional i was going to carry
on
it was not me
i just want to clarify right here right
now is not me so they're laughing the
other person
okay is laughing and he was laughing i'm
like okay are we just gonna like pretend
like it didn't happen are we gonna like
laugh about it
and what happened was the person
who was a grown man blamed it on me yeah
so he
[Laughter]
let me tell you something yeah if i ever
fart in front of you yeah it would
definitely be silent but deadly
never audibly never audibly you know
what i'm saying i'm a lady
this summer you must you're going to be
causing like nerd gasms in people
because like
to be
just because the poor nerds won't know
they won't understand because you're
that's why they're gasming yes yes
they'll be happy they're casting but
they'll be confused because i like how
confused they just become
no because you're thanos in avengers
infinity war but you're also in deadpool
2. i know like what's the timeline
what's happening i don't understand
three weeks apart coming out three weeks
apart and avengers did well quite well
and and
we hope that deadpool will break all
those records
[Applause]
and this whole i mean
obviously you know i listed a lot of
your films there in your intro but you
haven't done these kind of big
blockbusters with cgi and explosions and
things are you liking
goonies
yeah
you start with goonies you kind of know
whether you do milk or no country for
old men it doesn't matter because you
started with goonies so therefore you
can get away with anything in the in the
show and as tonight you're back with a
beard fully bearded
because you did lose your beard and the
world lost its mind
well the the plan because i was i was
going from sea yeah
to
dune and i had to fly straight to jordan
i was like i wanted i wanted to have her
shave me to
tell the world and talk about plastic
you know about single-use plastics and
how we need to stop because i just know
my children haven't seen my face so it's
an important moment to go like all right
i'm gonna shave this
no better person to shave my beard than
amelia we'll break the internet and then
amelia couldn't do it because she had a
thing you know and she's parties
i was in covent garden pushing drunk
people off myself
if you
without her
we did by shaving our face but yes it
was supposed to be you know yes oh
we've got a picture of you you do look
remarkable
but wasn't this but this is the thing
where it was the same day as the muller
report came out and you were trending
over them
yeah that's a world turned upside down
my children wanted the beard back so my
wife she's like don't do that anymore
but but i mean she goes
and she's like don't do that again but
you've got a good chin thank you because
some beards are
on because they're hiding a tiny chin oh
yeah regina i think you've heard enough
we've heard plenty from you tonight
thank you very much
and what was nice was you kept your fans
up to date you posted uh videos of your
of your workouts here's one of the
videos of you working out
[Applause]
[Music]
were you involved in that ryan no i had
no idea
no for sure you did because it was very
indirect you were in that bathroom admit
it i was i filmed it
that was me and like did you run it past
uh josh that you were going to involve
his his stepmom in the movie oh yeah
barbra streisand no no i didn't talk to
josh about that no he just said yeah
yeah and i was like no you didn't yeah
i think he thought i was kidding i was
like no i did yeah and then there was i
can't really talk about there was a
point where i heard the song can i say
the one
yeah coming out of your mouth yeah the
papa papa can you hear me right coming
out of your mouth
handle keep going no no i wrote
papa do you see me
it's like
can you
[Applause]
but even margie might be put off
sometimes by uh sometimes you don't use
something with your hair some of the
hairstyle in this you're you've gone
blonde in skyfall but you're classic bad
hair it won you an oscar in no country
for old men now i always assume that
it is genius
i would say it was a wig but it wasn't a
wig no it wasn't a wig unfortunately not
i had to live with that for two months
in santa fe
yeah and uh and no matter what i did
with it it will always taste that shape
so when i went to buy something on the
supermarket everybody will freak out
and didn't you have to wear a hair net
all the time yeah i had to wear a night
and then yeah like yeah
to close the thing on place and then the
last day of shooting i i went to shoot
and i have to take an elevator to go to
the first floor of a building where we
were shooting and the levator opens and
everybody on the crew were uh wearing
the coin brothers were right there in
front of me with their
with a thing was it the her name
yeah i know and then i realized like
that's scary it's scary because you were
so scary in that film it's it's freaky
that's what they pay me for
i'm such a nice boy you are
your mother is uh is she is she famous
in sweden she is famous in sweden
no she is not famous but she has sort of
she hung a lot with a kind of
avant-garde cool people like abba back
in the days yes those avant-gardes
they finally went mainstream i mean they
just
they really sold out
but she worked with abby didn't she
so what she did was do you know this
this is good trivia no she did she i
think she was dating a man called ron
spalding and he took all of their cover
images of their lps
actually she is on
one of the covers
which you apparently have i do
so uh we all know this album don't we
ladies and gentlemen abba there they are
in the back of the car drinking and um
we turn it around we turn it around
now
which one of these people is your mother
wait if i do this can you see the
similarities
oh yes
here we go
rebecca ferguson's mother's legs
um
not translate but she went through all
of the lyrics in swedish and really
helped rewrite them to english uh
waterloo
really should there's any mistakes it's
her fault
it does make no sense but um
i was talking about it seems like you're
quite enjoying the press store you're
having a nice
time yeah you know if you're gonna jump
in the water you may as well swim yeah
it's fun you saw there's a picture of
you in rome enjoying it yeah
oh there we are oh there we are oh boy
yeah i could feel josh falling deeper
and deeper there
that is like your honeymoon picture it
really is like it looks sort of like cgi
in the background like we didn't we
weren't actually outside we weren't
actually in yeah well like this morning
i mean i i told him this this morning i
wrote a text to him last night and i
said you know i've really had a good
time like these things cannot be so fun
and then sometimes they can be fun and i
said you could have no idea it was a
love letter it was a lovely one
it was a very intimate love letter that
i felt really good about not only how it
was written but the heart behind it and
then this morning i went down to the gym
and the first person i see the only
person i see in the gym is him and you
want to do nothing but avoid the person
that you wrote the textbook
we both barely made eye contact
very awkward but you you had feelings
for ryan before you met ryan
are you telling me this or is this
something you had something you said you
said it no i have said it i saw the
proposal and i have no shame in saying
that even though i saw it alone all
three times
i was a fan wow i am a fan i just can't
you know not wrap my head around you
sitting and watching the proposal
no no not at all
[Music]
i can see you watching and just being
like this guy no no no no i felt
that when i saw green lantern okay
uh timothy you didn't you you didn't win
you didn't win but if it was a
competition i'm talking about your
effort to do well in was it an exam
about
statistics god christ yes this is true i
i got a d in that yeah you got a d i got
a d but but but
i mean i i i deserve that or or worse
but anyway so you're in school you're
doing an exam statistics your teacher
she's miss lauten
yes
lawton lot miss lawton and so
what were the other kids doing were the
other kids just doing
uh yeah variation i mean i mean
some people presented parabolas and
things that were
more appropriate for statistics uh you
know varied projects mine was not so
tell the people what you decided to do
like a statistics song
yes sort of a sort of statistics rap
yeah horrible bad bad level worst level
but no you came up with a whole rap
persona didn't you yeah but not for that
i just had it oh
so lil is it little timmy tim yeah it's
part of my uh
[Music]
how do we have this film did you post it
how does this film make sure i posted it
i did it with a friend on a green screen
in school and i'm pointing to different
i was going to photoshop my teacher's
face in but i got too lazy so now
they're just kind of weird in the video
i'm pointing around and there's there's
nothing
well here are the statistical
rap stylings of little timmy tips
statistics
me on tv
[Music]
yep
excellent
[Applause]
[Music]
you